all right so i'm making like a little
documentary oh it's like a movie but
nobody has any lines and nobody even
knows what it is while they're making it
um
no
tell me about what's life like it's
pretty much common knowledge that it
takes at least 20 shells to have a
community my cousin fell asleep in a
pocket and that's why i don't like the
saying everything comes out of the wash
because sometimes it doesn't or
sometimes it does and they're just like
a completely different person
so it's actually only two of us now
myself and my grandmother nana connie we
like to watch 60 minutes because leslie
stahl is fearless
nana
[Music]
sometimes i find my mind wandering
thinking
what would my family think
do you think they could be out there
let's forget about being afraid just
take the adventure okay
let's do it
[Music]
hi everybody it's marcel i'm recording
this video because i'm looking for my
family
[Music]
marcel michelle and the search for a
family reunited
marcel how long has it been since you've
seen your family i couldn't tell you but
a space in my heart gets bigger and
louder every day
dean do you know how long that's two
years two years yeah oh that's nice to
know
[Music]
there's so many places that they could
be
marcel the shell with shoes on
you are beautiful
there must be so many others like me
he has got to go
not that i don't like arthur
not that come out
no oh my god no no oh
[Music]
[Music]
you